the kerbside recycling collection scheme
that operates in team bridge now makes
it easier than ever to recycle more and
more from the comfort of your own home
most households in team bridge will be
given these containers for their waste
they'll have a green bin for composting
a black bin for landfill
and a black recycling box and a green
recycling box
however if you don't have room at your
property for all of these containers you
may be given sacks and if you live in a
communal property you'll be given these
bins to share
let's take a look at what can go into
your green recycling box
any glass bottle or jar so it could be
clear green or brown glass it doesn't
matter
we also take mixed plastic bottles so
that's any plastic bottle you use in the
household that could be
a fizzy drinks bottle
it could be a shampoo bottle it could
even be a detergent bottle as long as
it's a bottle and it's plastic that's
fine
however it might be a good idea to
actually squash your bottles before you
put them into your green box because we
have so many of them so remember once
you've washed it
however please remember that we can't
take all types of plastic in your
recycling box we can only take plastic
bottles
we don't want things like plastic food
trays or plastic food containers these
are all made out of so many different
grades of plastic it's really difficult
to recycle them
they have to go into your landfill bin
or if you ever visit the brunell road
recycling centre you can take them there
if you have any old mobile phones
printed cartridges or batteries like
these
you can pop them into a small plastic
bag
put them on your recycling box
and the crew will take them for you
so what can we put in the black
recycling box well any type of white
paper can go in there so that's going to
be your newspapers
magazines pieces of white office paper
directories catalogues and even white
window envelopes even ones with plastic
in you don't need to take that out
anymore that can stay in there
if you're not sure about what type of
paper you've got or whether it's colored
or whether it's white there's a simple
rule if it tears white it's all right so
for example if you get a magazine
tear a piece of the paper
if the fibers are white the little tiny
white hairy fibers there that means
that's fine to be recycled
what we don't want in the box is
anything like tissue paper or kitchen
roll because that's no good for
recycling that can go into a green
compost bin
textiles have now been added to the list
of things that can be recycled from home
so for example if you've got
old shirts jumpers
t-shirts
towels
blankets curtains even paired shoes
these can all be recycled from home all
you need to do
place them in a carrier bag
and tie it up
and leave it beside your recycling boxes
on your normal recycling collection day
however try not to use a black sack
because that could be mistaken for
ordinary refuse
can you make sure that all of your
textiles that you put out for collection
are clean and dry we don't want soiled
items
so as well as newspapers and magazines
you can also put old food and drink cans
in your black box as well
that could be anything like these old
food cans
it can even be
metal lids from your glass jars they can
go in as well so it's always a good idea
to pop them in your old cans maybe
squash them and then they won't fall out
when they're in your black box
it also includes aerosols as well
they're either made from steel or
aluminium so they can be recycled too
dirty food cans and jars can be smelly
so it's a good idea to keep your
recycling boxes clean by rinsing them
out using old dishwater it's also a lot
nicer for the collection cruise
if you sometimes forget what goes where
we have these free color box stickers
which are available from team bridge
recycling department and they'll help
you to remember
so let's take a look at what we can put
into the green composting bin
it's really important that we get this
bit right
firstly you can put any food waste in
there so it could be cooked food waste
uncooked food waste meat scraps plate
scrapings tea bags egg shells veggie
peelings
any food waste can go inside
all householders will have been given a
kitchen caddy to make it easier to put
all the compostable waste in the kitchen
it's a good idea to line your caddy with
a caddy liner so that your green bin
stays clean and smell free
remember that we only accept caddy
liners that are 100 compostable
and these should be light green with
dark green writing like this
brown paper caddy liners can also be
used
any other colored compostable bag will
not be accepted
this is so that the crew can easily tell
the difference between an approved liner
or a plastic bag
alternatively you can wrap your food
waste in newspaper
as well as food waste you can put garden
waste in your green bin too that can
include grass cuttings
hedge cuttings
as long as they're no more than seven
centimeters thick
but we don't want any soil in the
compost bin
we also accept thin cardboard in your
green composting bin
for example cereal packets
fruit packets
even egg boxes
but we don't want thick cardboard on
your green bin so say if you've had
something delivered like a big package
that would be thick cardboard
if you've got large amounts of thick
cardboard it's a good idea to take it to
your nearest recycling centre but if you
can't just put it into your black bin
please don't put anything in your green
bin that isn't compostable for example
textiles plastic bags and even these
cardboard drinks cartons you may think
they're just cardboard but they do
actually have a waxy lining inside that
wouldn't break down
before your green bin is emptied the
collection crew will look inside to make
sure that everything in there is
compostable
if they find something that isn't they
will sticky your bin and it won't be
emptied that week and you'll have to put
it out the following week with your
black bin so it all goes to landfill
so that just leaves us with your black
bin
that's for anything that cannot be
recycled or composted
please don't put stuff in there that
could have gone into your recycling
boxes or your green bin it's a wasted
resource because this will go straight
to landfill
please make sure that your bins and
boxes are out by 7am on your day of
collection and remember that any rubbish
left on top of or beside your bin will
not be taken unless by prior arrangement
you